there's a lot of chatter of the is he or
isn't he when it comes to the next
spider-man
so let me just ask you i know what you
were gonna bust then i was like is he
originally what like what's the where is
this going well where is it going
to you tell me okay as you sip your
water let me ask you this how would you
feel about ever having your spidey back
on the big screen in some form okay so
the problem with this question is that
like it can be taken out of like you
could take my answer out of context and
you can just like make it into a thing
so like to be really clear how would i
feel
hypothetically
if
my spider-man was put into the one
that's about to come out
how would i feel hypothetically if
it is too big a question for me to ask
it really is like it's too
like it's there are so many because i
would have to like know what the story
was and also like
is it is it something like do i would i
ever want to do that again i'm not it's
a too big a question to answer in like
the end of a fight like a five minute
into like i have no idea i have
absolutely no idea
all i can say is i'm super excited
about tom holland
being the character and i i love him as
spider-man and i'm excited to see what
he what happens and what he does in this
next film
tammy fay
what'd you do hello mother this is jim
baker my husband
it's all part of our mission to help
people anyone who's hurting or they feel
like they've been left out god has a
plan for us
what'd he tell you to do this time
[Music]
i was just talking to jessica
and gosh she's just the best um what was
it like for you to work with her on this
project and to have such uh you know
such an intimate and complicated
relationship that you were portraying
together
yeah i mean you know she's such a
consumer actor and and she's one of one
of the best out there and and
what you know and obviously it's amazing
that this is such a
passion project for her and has been for
so long that's immediately reassuring
and uh
made me very confident that that she
wasn't gonna
mess around and
and that and that it was going to be a
really devoted kind of kind of thing to
to bring tammy to life and
and i was heartened that she wanted me
to help bring jim to life because she
knew she she you know she knew that i
was i wasn't gonna
scrimp on jim in the sense of um
you know we wanted to create something
very real we wanted to create something
that was
a kind of um a deeper version of what
people
associate with with these people because
you know there's been
so much said and and portrayed about
about these two people and
and there's been it's been a very very
superficial kind of shallow
uh
portrayal uh hopefully until now where
where we get underneath the surface of
how how how people present themselves
and how the media presents them so i
think that was our main thing is and
also like at the beginning of their
journey just these two kids genuinely in
love like yeah the foundation of their
relationship was
was really quite genuine as far as we
understand and we really want that was
really important for us to because
otherwise
as
the rifts happen and the splits happen
and the life gets complicated and
you know there's aim there's
you know immoral behavior on both sides
suddenly if if you start with that true
love
that's you have you have a story to tell
yeah it's all the more painful
um
you uh you guys are you're spectacular
in this i'm like
i'll see at the oscars basically um but
the transformations also are of course
is something everybody's talking about
what was it like for you when you would
show up and you'd see jessica in the
full prosthetics and the eyes and the
wigs and all that
yeah it was amazing it was a slow it was
a slow process we um we would start by
doing dialect sessions together and
talking in character and because you
know very very specific accent work that
we did with our
wonderful dialect coach liz himmelstein
and
obviously tammy's from minnesota and i'm
fr and jim is from michigan by way of
kind of southern baptist because he's
been growing up listening to falwell and
all and like trying to replicate their
rhythms so that was very specific to get
into that first and then we would start
sending pictures of the prosthetic tests
to each other and getting each other's
opinion and trying to inspire each other
and whatnot and then
i know there was one day where i was
where i was like oh yeah there she is
there's tammy there and and
her and her team just spent the whole
day really
zeroing in on one of her iconic looks
for a screen test and
to get some photos for the film
and it was that moment of like oh this
is gonna be great this is like
these artists at work combined with
jessica's artistry it's gonna be
it's gonna be really um really special
and how is it to see yourself
older i mean i know you're a hymn but
what is it like when you see that yeah
it doesn't feel like me that's what it's
really is fine because it's like i have
a prosthetic it's not me it's nothing to
do with me really
that that part of things but no i i
i did that like i did that face app
thing
when like when that face app thing was a
thing
yeah russia was stealing of the images
of our face or whatever and i was i i
didn't sign up for i borrowed my friends
one and i didn't mind like my i i'm i'm
okay if that's the way i look when i'm
older i'm grand like it's fine i don't
i'm i'm cool with it like it i look like
kind of like a
skinny santa claus i was fine with it
you know what maybe that part's in your
future santa claus what are you talking
about like rail fit santa
it's a new take the origin story i heard
that uh the family would come to set or
they at least came at one time what was
that like for you all to meet them the
family that did come to visit it was a
beautiful beautiful thing
of course like horribly pressurizing and
terrifying and you want to run away and
you want to say i'm sorry for everything
i've done and like you know because you
feel because these this is like like
you know you can't take it lightly and i
don't and neither does jessica they
needed anyone making the film it's like
these people lived some of them are
still living jim is still alive and well
and he's you know he's he's doing what
he's doing um
and so
the the weight of that responsibility is
oh gosh it's um and then yeah yeah you
know you have their relatives and their
children and their cousin like everyone
you know so it's
real it's very real and it's
you know it's we're all we're all like
life life ain't no joke and and people's
lives on you know no one's life should
be
kind of um minimized or diminished or
undercut or um
you know uh mocked or uh and and of
course we we were attempting to do the
opposite of all of that tell the story
yeah tammy and i are undergoing the most
vicious attacks
serving god don't feel like it should be
a money-making opportunity you know when
i saw that clipping with my face on it i
thought for a second that you were proud
of me
oh tammy faye you follow blindly in the
end all you are is blind
[Music]
i just want to love people
the devil's coming for me tammy can we
talk about satan leader
[Music]
you